[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo le meilleur de la
semaine politique et parlementaire avec
à mes côtés kathia gilder bonjour katia
bonjour oriane et nous accueillons
aujourd'hui julien bargeton bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateur la république
en marge de paris on va refaire la
semaine avec vous c'est une volonté d'
emmanuel macron instauré un service
national obligatoire mais sous quelle
forme
un rapport parlementaire préconise un
parcours de citoyenneté
le parlement a adopté la proposition de
loi sur le régime d'asile européen les
députés ont voté tel quel le texte du
sénat mais il a dit viser jusque dans la
majorité
le scandale lactalis à l'ordre du jour
au sénat des responsables de la grande
distribution étaient auditionnés ils ont
avoué leur part de responsabilité et
puis la nouvelle calédonie les sénateurs
ont voté le projet de loi organique qui
définit le corps électoral en vue du
futur référendum et on commence tout de
suite la semaine avec le service
national va-t-il voir le jour et sous
quelle forme
les députés ont remis leur rapport cette
semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était une promesse du président de la
république il en a d'ailleurs précisé
les contours cette semaine pour lui le
service civique doit être universel et
obligatoire pour une période de trois à
six mois
mais ce n'est pas l'avis des députés qui
ont remis leur rapport cette semaine il
préconise un parcours de citoyenneté en
trois étapes est allé de 11 à 25 ans
nathalie gloire c'était un rapport très
attendu mais la commission défense de
l'assemblée nationale a été prise de
vitesse
avant même sa présentation par les
députés emmanuel macron a proposé mardi
soir que le service national comporte
une partie obligatoire de trois à six
mois d annonce confirmée hier par le
porte parole du gouvernement
ce sera obligatoire ce sera universel et
donc ça concernera tant les jeunes
garçons que les jeunes filles et ce sera
pour une période de trois à six mois des
propositions qui vont à l'opposé des
préconisations des parlementaires les
rapporteurs souhaité eu un parcours d
citoyenneté étalés entre l'âge de 11 à
25 ans face à ce désaveu les députés
défendent tant bien que mal leurs
conclusions
notre rapport est le fruit d'une
quarantaine d'auditions et il est aussi
le fruit d'échangés de rencontres avec
plus d'une centaine de d'experts sur ces
questions là je nous n'avons pas à
commenter la la prise de parole ce n'est
pas notre rôle nous ne sommes pas dans
ce registre là un nouveau rapport va
être remis à l'exécutif d'ici la fin du
mois d'avril
en attendant les députés eux sont loin
d'être convaincus par le dispositif
voulu par emmanuel macron service
national universel tel qu'il est proposé
par le prénom la république est une
promesse démagogique impossible à
réaliser
ces 20 milliards d'euros sur l'ensemble
du quinquennat le coût d'un tel service
c'est ça correspond à la hausse de la
csg des françaises doivent subir
arrêtons arrêtons d'amuser la galerie
avec des propositions qui au final ne se
feront pas ou consisteront uniquement à
du recyclage apparence une phase
d'expérimentation du service national
universel et déjà prévue en 2019 je
viens large temps on voit que c'est un
sujet qui divise alors les députés au
lieu de la séquence obligatoire voulue
par emmanuel macron préconise eu ce
parcours de citoyenneté est ce que ça
vous paraît pertinent est ce que ça sera
suivie par la république en marche sur
le sujet du service civique universel je
veux voir plutôt les convergences
on voit que il ya une proposition de
députés il ya bien sûr l'engagement du
président de la république mais qui
répond à un besoin
on voit bien que nous devons retrouver
ce lien
au sein de la nation vous savez c'est là
la devise de la république liberté
égalité fraternité
à quoi correspond la fraternité où on
voit quand il ya des événements graves
ç'avait été le cas que les attentats que
la nation a besoin de se retrouver
on avait vu cet incroyable ça te croit
de manifestations le 11 janvier 2015
donc il y a un lien profond étroit qui
nous unit au delà des règles juridiques
mais que nous avons du mal à faire vivre
et à définir c'est ce que henri bergson
par exemple appeler le supplément d'âme
comment donner un supplément d'âme alors
on le voit il y a plusieurs propositions
sur sur la table est ce que je crois moi
c'est que il faut travailler pour
arriver à souder davantage la nation
notamment auprès des jeunes pour
expliquer ce que ça veut dire qu'être
français
qu'est ce que c'est que la république
qu'est ce que c'est que l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes
cette faille est vrai c'est que la la
cité voilà quels sont les ferments
historiques qui ont construit la france
et notamment avec la révolution est
repoussé on voit bien que le président
la république avait eu cette intuition
pendant sa campagne il ya d'autres
propositions sur la table
il faut y travailler un oui vous êtes
plutôt d'accord sur le principe vous
dites il a eu cette institution mais
dans les faits on voit bien qu'il ya un
rapport d'à côté des propositions on a
du mal à voir comment tout ça se met en
ordre
est ce que vous pensez qu'il n'y a pas
un peu une précipitation voire même une
certaine cacophonie sur ce dossier donc
la france a été meurtri par des
attentats la france à un moment voulu
trouver les occasions de ce2 ce1 de se
rencontrer elle même et on le fait dans
des événements plutôt grave il ya
parfois des événements bout notamment
attentat où on arrive on comprend ce que
c'est qu'être français là tout d'un coup
tout d'un coup on a vu ce qu'il faisait
ce lien indéfectible et on a réussi à le
faire vibrer à le faire vivre mais sous
l'eau sous le choc d'un grand malheur
est le sujet qui est posé c'est comment
le faire vivre sur une durée plus longue
donc sur l'effectivité de la mesure
julien bargeton notamment d'entendre des
critiques sur le coup on entend un coût
de 20 à 30 milliards le sénat l'estiment
à 30 milliards est-ce qu'ils auraient
les moyens de mettre en oeuvre cette
mesure
il faudra trouver les moyens de mettre
en oeuvre cette mesure notamment pour
qu'elle soit budgétairement raisonnable
acceptable donc là la proposition des
propositions sont sur la table trois
mois six mois il y a encore des
expérimentations à mener des
concertations aussi à conduire et nous
regarderons comment le système peut
s'appliquer pour que c'est brice c'est
moi une question de tuyauterie je pense
qu'une question de contenu c'est à dire
qu'est-ce qu'il faut communiquer
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire comprendre
aux jeunes pour qu'ils vivent
intensément la république j'allais
presque dire dans leur chair c'est très
difficile c'est un sujet à laquelle à
laquelle se heurtent aux sages et auquel
se heurtent la république depuis
longtemps parce qu'on voit bien ce que
sont les règles juridiques
on a plus de mal à faire corps autour de
la république julien bargeton il ya un
autre dossier qui a suscité beaucoup de
polémique cette semaine peu avant minuit
ce jeudi les députés ont voté une
proposition de loi sur le
droit d'asile vote définitif puisque
l'assemblée a adopté le texte conforme
c'est-à-dire le même texte que celui
voté par le sénat
il devait faciliter le placement en
rétention des étrangers arrêtés en
france mais dont la demande d'asile
relève d'un autre pays européen
c'est une première dans les rendent en
marche hier soir le gouvernement a fait
face à un acte de résistance de 30
députés de sa majorité emmenée par
martin bonheur médecins et ancienne
directrice du samu social
il conteste le durcissement du texte
opérée par le sénat je lis à cet article
2 que le mot demandeurs d'asile devient
dans le texte l'étranger ce changement
de terminologie et choquant il meurt tu
m'aimes il traduit un a priori qui n'est
pas dans notre tradition d'accueil
parmi les mesures polémique le
raccourcissement du délai de sept à
quinze jours pendant lequel les migros
peuvent contester une décision de
transfert comment exercer un droit de
recours vis-à-vis du rouleau compresseur
de la procédure d'éloignement
comment trouver traducteur est avocat et
ester en justice
en moins de six jours sans bafouer les
droits
cela sera impossible le gouvernement
soutenu par une majorité de députés en
marche affirme vouloir voter ce texte en
urgence pour faire face à la forte
pression migratoire la conscience et
l'engagement sont de belles choses mais
ici personne n'a de leçon à recevoir
dans ce domaine là est ce que nous
devons faire ici c'est voter la loi mais
le gouvernement vous demande le retrait
de ses amendements pour que le texte
puisse être adopté très rapidement
au total deux amendements ont été
retirés et deux soumis au vote des
rejetés le gouvernement a toutefois
promis que les ajustements pourraient
être fait pendant le projet de loi asile
et immigration
comme le rappelle la future rapporteur
du texte on a deux mois pour préparer le
pgi l asile immigration pour procéder
aller aux auditions les plus précises
les plus techniques possibles et pour
travailler sur cd v là vous avez
l'engagement de notre groupe
le projet de loi asile et immigration
sera au conseil des ministres mercredi
prochain et arrivera à l'assemblée début
avril
alors ce texte a suscité beaucoup de
remous en commission finalement séance
les députés de la majorité dont vous
faites partie sénateurs donc on vous ont
dû retirer les amendements nombreux
qu'ils avaient déposées on a un peu
l'impression d'un vote sous pression du
gouvernement est ce que c'est le cas sur
le sujet de l'asile concernant cette
proposition
il s'agit de combler un vide juridique
créée par la cour de cassation donc il
faut y répondre
parce que nous devons trouver les moyens
de pouvoir
cette question rires notamment et
notamment de oui il fallait combler un
vide juridique c'est à dire que ce vide
juridique qui empêchait finalement
d'assurer d'un certain côté la
souveraineté de l'état
il s'agissait de cela et bien doit être
comblé ensuite il faudra trouver
l'équilibré dans le texte à venir
asile immigration moi je fais confiance
à élise falaise qui est député de paris
d'un arrondissement fin dans un
arrondissement notamment où ce sujet est
bien connu dans le xème donc elle pourra
mener les auditions travail avec le
gouvernement pour trouver cet équilibre
entre notre tradition d'accueil la
france est généreuse et aussi la
nécessité d'être plus efficace
certains dénoncent le texte moi je
voudrais aussi dénoncé parfois
l'hypocrisie et la complexité de la
situation actuelle parce que nous avons
désormais cent mille demandeurs d'asile
à peu près beaucoup plus que dans les
années précédentes
il faut accueillir et intégrer mieux
ceux qui ont droit
mais en revanche pouvoir tout simplement
transférer n'ont pas droit dans les pays
notamment si l'on travaille traversé des
pays dits convention de dublin
donc c'est ça l'objectif seulement un
moyen de combler un vide juridique ou
est-ce que c'est aussi un moyen de un
avertissement un moyen de mettre la
pression sur gérard collomb pour qu'elle
adoucit salines lors de l'examen du
texte asile immigration
vous savez moi j'avais une personnalité
qui était importante dans mon engagement
politique et qui était michel rocard
michel rocard avait eu cette phrase très
célèbre la france ne peut pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde mais elle doit
prendre sa part dans l'asile nous devons
répondre à cette obligation républicaine
ancien qui est d'accueillir et
d'intégrer les personnes qui ont droit à
l'asile parce qu' ils répondent aux
critères et c'est d'ailleurs l'orgueil
et la fierté de la france d'avoir cette
tradition bien ancrée
mais en même temps il ne faut pas tomber
dans la naïveté qui consiste à refuser
de réfléchir à tous les outils qui nous
permettent d'être plus efficace par
exemple pour les délais de recours pour
également sujet d'immigration les délais
c'est pas une question de suivre une
ligne
c'est tout simplement de dire comment on
est à la fois efficaces parce que l'état
a à garder sa souveraineté et en même
temps comment répond à notre tradition
d'accueil et je suis convaincu que le
gouvernement devra dans ce sens là qui a
toujours été celui de la france mais
nous devons tenir compte de cette
situation nouvelle créée par les flux
que vous connaissez désormais on va
passer à un autre sujet à venir
marchethon le scandale lactalis à
l'ordre du jour au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
audition sous tension au palais du
luxembourg les sénateurs ont auditionné
des représentants de la grande
distribution impliqué dans le scandale
du lait contaminé
compte rendu de solenn nicolas ils
reconnaissent des défaillances
l'exécution dans certains magasins a été
défaillante
malheureusement un certain nombre de
produits ont été remis par mégarde dans
le circuit de distribution des produits
contaminés remise en rayon par mégarde
est réuni hier par le sénat les
professionnels de la distribution fait
face aux questions et à l'indignation
vous avez une pratique avec vos salariés
qui fait que voulait filmer pour savoir
s'ils volent dans les rayons et vous
allez nous dire qu'il ya des salariés
qui peuvent aller remettre dans les
rayons des produits qui sont ramenés par
le consommateur
je me pose vraiment des questions sur
cette source de surfer sur ces choses là
des erreurs humaines c'est donc l'une
des principales explications données par
les distributeurs lors de cette table
ronde qui intervient alors qu'une
nouvelle plainte a été déposée hier par
l'organisation foodwatch une plainte qui
vient s'ajouter à celle du fondateur de
l'association des victimes de lactalis
déposée contre l'industriel et les
pharmaciens
quentin guillemin attendait des réponses
qu'il n'a pas obtenue est les réponses à
sont pas satisfaisantes parce qu'on
parle de réponse ponctuelle des réponses
qui sont envahis reçurent des erreurs
humaines
les solutions sont pas sont pas au
rendez vous parmi les solutions
proposées par les grandes enseignes de
distribution des propositions
technologique et plus de moyens humains
pour un meilleur contrôle
enfin une meilleure collaboration entre
industriels et commerçants vient la
rejetons le directeur général de
l'alimentation assure que lactalis
savait que la salmonelle et est présente
dans l' usine de crâne mais que le
groupe l'a caché à l'état en ne
transmettant pas à les résultats de ses
autocontrôles est ce que l'état ne
devrait pas renforcer ses procédures est
ce qui n'est pas qu'aux responsables de
cette crise
c'est une crise sanitaire importante et
qui a touché des familles des enfants et
donc évidemment qui est extrêmement
grave
je note que ce groupe lactalis
à conserver un culte du secret qui n'est
plus tout à fait ce qu'on attend d'une
entreprise responsable au 21e siècle et
il a caché les auto contrôle l'état ne
pouvait pas deviner qu'on lui masquer
des choses et je note que l'état a réagi
très vite dès lors qu'il a eu
connaissance pour demander le retrait
des produits et pour procéder aussi à la
poursuite contre contre c'est contre ces
manoeuvres
donc il y a il y a eu une réaction de
l'état ensuite il y a eu vraiment un
problème dans la distribution qui a
remis certains produits alors qu'il ne
fallait pas les remettre
et ça c'est la responsabilité des
entreprises vous savez quand on a la
liberté de créer et d'entreprendre
ça va avec la responsabilité et la
responsabilité c'est aussi à sanctionner
et puis ce groupe qui a mis beaucoup de
temps pour s'excuser qui a des pratiques
un peu anciennes et à mon avis se prend
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle une une
crise en termes de communication et
voyez quand on anticipe sur des
pratiques et bien on évite ce genre de
choses et notamment en étant beaucoup
plus prompte et beaucoup plus sérieux
sur les contrôles sanitaires
il y a des les enquêtes judiciaires qui
vont être ouverts puisqu'il ya un dépôt
de plainte et on verra ensuite la
responsabilité de chacun mais je crois
que ce n'est quand même pas la
responsabilité de l'état qui est engagée
là mais bien celle du producteur et du
distributeur
en revanche cela n'exclut pas notamment
dans la loi à venir à la suite des états
généraux de l'alimentation à réfléchir à
des sanctions le par exemple plus
importantes pour ce type de pratique le
principe d'une commission d' enquête sur
la sphère lactalis est sous type
d'affaires en général a été actée à
l'assemblée est ce que vous pensez que
la représentation nationale peu
faire la lumière sur ce qui sur cette
affaire sachant qu'elle ne peut empiéter
sur des procédures judiciaires en cours
que ça sert à quelque chose c'est trop
bien cette enquête
je pense que la commission d' enquête
sur lactalis est très utile parce que
elle peut d'abord déboucher sur une
meilleure compréhension de la situation
sans empiéter bien sûr sur laquelle
judiciaire mais aussi sur des
propositions déboucher sur des
propositions pourquoi pas des
amendements à apporter à la loi que va
défendre
stéphane travert si il y à des
améliorations à apporter
donc je crois que nous sommes
typiquement dans le cas où le rôle du
parlement est utile parce que au travers
d'une crise et qui a été sérieuse pour
les familles concernées et bien le
parlement se saisisse du sujet pour
proposer et aller plus loin voilà je
crois que nous verrons quelles sont les
propositions qui débouche de cette
commission
on va prendre un peu de distance julien
bargeton puisqu'on va évoquer le futur
statut de la nouvelle calédonie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sénat a examiné le projet de loi
organique sur l'organisation du
référendum les sénateurs se sont mis
d'accord sur la composition des listes
électorales jardin klein deux mois après
la visite d'edouard philippe en nouvelle
calédonie le projet de loi visant à
encadrer le référendum d'indépendance
est arrivé au sénat en décembre dernier
le premier ministre avait rappelé le
rôle primordial de l'état dans
l'organisation de cette consultation
les 21 acteurs de ce processus il
incombe à lui comme les autres partis
processus
unique que
dans notre histoire
est assez unique
l'ensemble puisse se dérouler calmement
au sénat deux amendements ont été
adoptés en séance publique
l'un concernant le remboursement des
dépenses de campagne et l'autre
entourant les temps d'antenne entre
présidents de groupe au congrès mais
avant tout ce processus passe notamment
par la définition du corps électoral
le texte prévoit une procédure
exceptionnelle d'inscription d'office
sur les listes électorales ils seront
inscrits tous les électeurs résidant en
nouvelle calédonie depuis au moins six
mois
mais également ce natif de lille et
gardant des intérêts matériels et moraux
sur le territoire une disposition
dérogatoire au droit électoral commun
mais autorisés par la constitution
c'est une nouveauté en soi mais ça fait
partie de ces nombreuses étrangeté de la
nouvelle-calédonie étrangeté non pas
parce que c'est étrange et parce que cet
étranger au droit électoral commun que
l'on a en france
mais en france métropolitaine mais
également dans les hôtels trois
outre-mer
si la loi est adoptée par les deux
chambres le corps électoral pour le
référendum de novembre 2018 passerait de
150000 à 170 mille électeurs alors on
voit bien toutes les précautions prises
que tout a été fait pour que le scrutin
soit indiscutable mais on pressent quand
même un rejet d'eaux finale de
l'indépendance est ce que vous ne pensez
pas vous ne craignez pas une
recrudescence des violences un peu comme
en corse
la nouvelle connue la nouvelle calédonie
avait connu des périodes de violence sa
remontée puis un processus mené voilà
sur plusieurs années dans les années 90
a permis pour progressivement de
débouchés je crois qu'il ne faut pas
revenir en arrière sur l'autonomie apa
retiendra bien sûr aux nouveaux
calédoniens de voter et de sur le
référendum
mais ce que je crois c'est que nous
devons dans la république adapter aussi
les situations à la les propositions à
la réalité des territoires
il faut prendre en compte les
spécificités d'un territoire très
particulier le point d'initier rendu s'y
est rendu
le président de la république je crois
va y aller dc dc mais le message à faire
passer c'est que évidemment dans la
république
eh bien nous savons nous adapter et je
ne crois pas que les temps soit un recul
sur voilà les capacités d'agir
localement et ça vaut d'ailleurs sur
notre territoire je ne peux pas on peut
pas forcément comparé ce serait
dangereux de comparer la corse
la nouvelle calédonie mais je crois que
dans l'esprit l'idée c'est quand même
que nous soyons modernes et une
république du 21e siècle c'est une
république qui a dâ qui expérimentent et
qui sait prendre en compte la
spécificité de ces territoires
on va maintenant passer à la partie
politique de cette émission avec notre
partenaire du figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour vous interroger on accueille gym
gère assez bon aujourd'hui morjan
bonjour katia bonjour julien bargeton
putsch le groupe des macros nist on
l'appelle comme ça au conseil de paris
anne hidalgo a organisé jeudi soir la
nuit des solidarités pour compter le
nombre de sdf dans les rues de paris
est-ce qu'il faut y voir une réponse au
gouvernement qui a accusé de
sous-estimer justement le nombre de sans
abri dans la capitale
je crois que personne n'a intérêt à
rentrer dans une bataille de chiffres
sur le sujet des sans abri et des
personnes qui sont dans la misère qui
souffrent beaucoup et l'état les
collectivités locales notamment la ville
de paris travaillent main dans la main
c'est une situation ancienne ce n'est
pas le gouvernement actuel qui a créé
les sans abri et nous savons depuis
voilà plusieurs années c'est réalité de
nos villes une réalité très malheureuse
nos vies et les les associations
d'ailleurs connaissent la situation
parfois même très personnellement des
sans abri sur l'opération de jeudi soir
c'était une opération légitime sans
arrière pensées politiques
6 s'il s'agit de compter comme cela a
été fait dans d'autres villes voilà
pourquoi mais je crois que à new york
notamment mais je crois pas que ce soit
le plus important le plus important
c'est de travailler pour améliorer la
situation
sortons des polémiques politiciennes et
disons nous quand même que conté ne
suffit pas s'il suffisait de dénombrer
les sans abri pour trouver des solutions
on le saurait et d'ailleurs les
associations connaissent déjà la
situation mais en revanche il faut c'est
proposer des solutions notamment sur un
parcours du logement ce sera l'objectif
de la loi est lent la loi portée par
julien de normandie et jacques mézard
sur le fait de faire comme dans certains
pays du nord certains pays scandinaves
où on met le logement d'abord par
exemple en évitant les expulsions
locatives ya tout de même eu des
maladresses de communication
de la part des macros nice on pense
notamment à sylvain maillard qui est un
élu parisien et puis qu assurer que la
majorité des sdf dorment et dans la rue
par choix est-ce que ça va pas créer un
contexte un peu particulier sur ce débat
sylvain maillard a reconnu la maladresse
de sa phrase qui a d'ailleurs été
amputée parce qu'il n'a pas exactement
dit cela pour le connaître je sais que
c'est un homme qui est empreint
d'humanisme et évidemment dans son for
intérieur il ne voulait absolument pas
dire cela parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
est profondément humain et comme le sont
d'ailleurs les habitants des grandes
villes qui souffrent aussi de voir ces
personnes dans la difficulté
donc ce que je pense sur ce sujet c'est
que de l'autre côté d'ailleurs aussi
certains ont voulu relancer le débat sur
les chiffres il ne s'agit pas d'un débat
sur les chiffres parce que les
situations sont très différentes vous
avez des personnes à la rue qui sont
seules des familles avec enfants des
gens qui souffrent de psychoses liés à
l'alcool des personnes migrantes donc il
faut à chaque fois des solutions
logement différentes et c'est là qu'est
la difficulté c'est que il faut être fou
faire du cas par cas et éviter un
certain nombre d'amalgamés et de
généralités qui n'apportent aucune
solution concrète pour l'épater minutes
dit sylvain maillard est un élu parisien
comme vous est-ce que avec lui avec
d'autres vous travaillez à proposer un
projet alternatif à anne hidalgo en vue
des prochaines municipales
la question n'est pas celle du rapport
de la république en marche à anne
hidalgo la majorité actuelle et c'est le
sujet qui est pour les municipales de
république en marche et que voulons-nous
pour les villes les grandes villes
notamment mais aussi les villes moyennes
les bourgs centres et comment on
construit
finalement une approche en marche des
territoires il y à des endroits
d'ailleurs ou des maires sortants ont
bien fait le travail se rapproche et
donc on peut regarder il n'y a pas
forcément de nécessité d'avoir des
candidats partout
ma conviction pour paris c'est qu' il
faudra un ou une candidat en marche dans
la ville de paris mais ce qu'il faut
d'abord et avant tout c'est une vision
stratégique de la ville on construire un
projet que veut ton pour le grand paris
comme en page est donc finalement des
pouvoirs solitaire des mères à un
pouvoir plus solidaire comment on ne
change de méthode et de périmètre
bon on fait la transition énergétique
hume et efficace pour la voilà les
sujets qui sont d'office est devant nous
et je crois que c'est c'est vraiment ça
qu'il faut pour être votre chien
construisons un projet et puis on verra
ça gonflement pour à toi la nature vous
dites à tous ceux qui avancent un peu
leurs pions pour sa benjamin griveaux
peut-être stanislas guérini etc c'est
pas le moment de la candidature de
l'incarnation la candidature là parlons
de projets le moment de la candidature
viendra et c'est légitime d'ailleurs les
ambitions personnelles sont les emails
sous mais elles sont légitimes et je
veux dire qu'il y aura d'autres villes
où ce sera le cas mais l'important c'est
de définir notre vision de paris paris
en grand c'est à dire qui est sorti des
frontières du périphérique
et puis les sujets prioritaires pour une
ville voilà ce que nous voulons dedans
merci julien bargeton d'avoir été
l'invité de parlement hebdo
merci à tous merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis et très bonne semaine sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]